hello there let's suppose you are
microsoft and you are releasing a huge
and awesome model how do you make it
obvious it is the best the biggest the
real thing
correct you compare your numbers of
parameters against the literature make a
beautiful plot where you are the top of
the line so congrats now everybody is
hailing you like you're the best of the
best and you might as well be miss
coffee bean is not here to claim
otherwise but what does the number of
parameters tell us about a model anyway
we came across a paper that tells us
about a bigger picture it argues that
the number of parameters alone is not
enough to compare against other models
and that reporting one number only about
a model can be highly misleading when it
comes to describing its efficiency in
other words a high number of parameters
does not necessarily mean that the model
has high capacity nor that it is slow so
get ready to get your mind enlarged as
we welcome you to this ai coffee break
thanks to alef alva for sponsoring this
video stick around until the end of the
video to learn more about them model
comparisons what is this all about well
we need to measure scientific progress
in deep learning one line of doing so is
to measure the model's quality on
specific tasks or benchmarks and to
measure how much of a sensible output
the model delivers but we do not talk
about this today nor does this paper
because today is all about model
efficiency which relates to how much
training a model costs how much one has
to pay to run inference for many users
and how long a user has to wait until
the model delivers the answer to
describe model efficiency the literature
uses things like we cite the number of
trainable parameters the number of
floating point operations and speed
throughput
but the point of this paper is that if
one chooses the right cost indicators
one can create a more favorable picture
for the model's efficiency than it is in
reality and that model comparisons
relying on only some of these metrics
can result in unfair and incomplete
comparisons this is what the authors
call the efficiency misnomer in other
words to avoid the current situation
where people are just choosing the
metric they shine at and ignore the
others the authors propose that well all
metrics should be reported when it comes
to comparing architectures in general
but what are these metrics and why does
one measure alone not suffice to
describe the computational cost of the
model why is miss coffee bean secret
model of 530 billion and one parameter
not automatically the best of the best
and also not necessarily the slowest
since it reportedly but don't fact check
this has the most parameters in the
world
well let's look at the efficiency
measure of floating point operations or
flops in short that is frequently used
to measure the computational cost in
literature the more operations you have
to do the more computations there need
to be executed by a piece of hardware
but as the authors point out we cite a
model with low flops may not actually be
fast given that flops does not take into
account information such as the degree
of parallelism or hardware related
details like the cost of a memory access
so supposing that model a has a lower
number of flops than the model b it
might as well be that model b is not
more efficient because the floating
point operations are not executed in
sequence like in a recurrent neural
network but in parallel all at the same
time like in a transformer or even more
maybe model b is better suited for the
hardware it runs on and for example
memory access is faster for model b than
for model a so even though model a has
lower flops than b model b could be much
more computationally efficient then
let's look at the number of trainable
parameters in a model which is also a
widely used measure for efficiency but
the others here draw the attention to
the fact that very few trainable
parameters can still be very slow
especially when the same parameters are
used in the same computation like it is
the case with convolutions in cnns and
with the feed forward layers in
transformers where the same feed forward
network so the same parameters are used
for each token as we discussed in a
previous video so while the number of
parameters from the fully connected
layer does not increase with the
sequence length for transformers the
compute and memory definitely do because
all these outputs for each feed forward
layer have to be computed and stored in
memory the authors highlight that the
number of parameters of a model is a
good proxy for knowing whether the model
fits in the memory but cannot be a cost
indicator or not alone also the number
of parameters is often used to imply the
capacity of the model in the sense of
its expressive power of capturing
complex function and dependencies
between input and output which is not
necessarily true because parameter
sharing which reduces the effective
number of parameters does not
necessarily decrease the model
expressivity just think about it if we
would remove the parameter sharing in
transformers and each token would have
its own feed forward neural network with
its own parameters which would make the
number of parameters increase linearly
with the sequence length would that
increase the accuracy of the model and
would that model necessarily learn a
better function no it wouldn't not
necessarily i mean we would have n
position specific feed forward neural
networks instead of just one but it's
questionable that this would model
anything better or that it would even
converge with the data amounts we have
currently because we would have removed
an important inductive bias of the
transformer which is that every token is
treated the same modulo what the
attention scores dynamically computed
beforehand and yes it does look like
increasing the number of parameters also
increases the model accuracy and quality
but is again it is just an impression we
get because the increase of number of
parameters usually comes with an
increase in training data and with some
specific architecture changes so no it's
not just about the number of parameters
but also about the architecture and its
inductive biases the data again the data
and then all the training gimmicks of
course other metrics like throughput and
speed which relate to how much a user
has to wait for the model to give an
answer strongly depend on hardware and
sometimes simply on the skill of the
programmer who implemented the whole
thing and does not necessarily speak of
an architecture on itself so this
measure again if used on its own is not
a fair comparison between models and
let's follow the paper a little closer
and dive into the discrepancy between
training and inference scenarios that
adds a whole new dimension to the
discussion depending on context training
inference or even both can be more
important to look at for example miss
coffee bean might not have the data the
compute or enough money to pay the
electricity bill of the tpus and gpus
that microsoft and google and other
likes have to train a huge model on
billions of data samples but she does
have enough vram to load the model and
find unit on more tasks this is one of
the appealing aspects of the pre-train
and fine-tune paradigm that one general
purpose model is trained just once and
the environmental damage is done only
once and this training cost we cite can
be very small compared to the inference
cost when a model is deployed to be used
by many many users but in cases where
retraining has to be done very often
like it is the case with recommender
systems that have to be kept up to date
with the user preferences and available
content at any moment the training cost
can become very important again on the
other hand if the inference efficiency
is the bottleneck because the deep
learning based application runs on
mobile phones then the inference speed
is very important so we have seen now
how different measures can disagree when
it comes to describing efficiency for
the same model and that one measure of
efficiency alone can be highly
misleading also the number of parameters
alone is not a measure for much else
than how large a storage the model needs
and that the more efficiency metrics a
paper reports the better especially to
be sure that nobody misses out on the
unfavorable metrics and speaking of
companies that have the means to crunch
the numbers for really large models
let's introduce our sponsor alef alpha
alef alpha's vision is quite simple to
be the leading european company
researching and creating next generation
strong artificial intelligence think of
it as europe's open ai but then forget
this again as it puts a european twist
to it i love this a little bit of
competition in ai from europe will
benefit everyone no aleph alpha's
european approach and data sets have an
impact beyond poor language
understanding this means they're going
multimodal so what they do best at lf
alpha is research and development in a.i
with the european focus they have a
diverse team of currently more than 30
senior experts from all relevant fields
working relentlessly to create truly
transformative ai technology which sure
leads to new ways for human machine
collaboration going of script now i know
some of the people working there and
they are great from research to
development to implementation ai must
benefit all of society and that's why lf
alpha strives to align modern
generalizable ai research sustainably
with ethical values and to achieve that
they search for the best talent and
partners so if you're looking for a job
make sure to check out alif alpha for
more information visit their website or
follow them on twitter see the links in
the description below thanks for
watching this episode and if you enjoyed
this do not forget to tell your own
coffee beans about this channel
[Music]